good day everyone happy new year and welcome i'm
jack van horn from the university of virginia and
please allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational health institute
of virginia the uva brain institute the college
of arts and sciences the school of data science
and through grants from the national institutes
of general medical sciences it is my delight and
privilege to welcome our speaker today dr
kevin pelphrey professor of neurology from
here at the university of virginia dr pelfrey is
a neuroscientist and expert on brain development
and he is the harrison wood jefferson
scholars foundation professor of neurology
and also the director of the center for healthy
brain development here at uva he earned his phd
at the university of north carolina in chapel hill
in 2001 and since he's had extensive experience
teaching and conducting research at leading
institutions such as carnegie mellon at duke
university as well as at yale before coming
to uva dr pelfrey served as the carbonell
family professor in autism and neurodevelopmental
disorders at george washington university
as well as the founding director of the autism and
neurodevelopmental disorders institute his team
seeks to better understand the causes of autism
spectrum disorder and related neurodevelopmental
disorders to deliver the right treatment to
the right individuals at the right time kevin
is a principal investigator of the nih autism
center of excellence program in particular the
neurogenetics of autism network he's uh certainly
is excuse me he's also served by appointment
of the secretary of health and human services as
a member of the interagency autism coordinating
committee his presentation today is entitled
building precision medicine for autism plural
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube and if you are watching
via youtube thank you so much for joining us today
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for dr pelfrey
via the chat feature in their zoom sessions i will
personally synthesize these questions collect them
and ask them on behalf on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that welcome kevin thank you so much we are
very excited to hear your lecture thank you thank
you very much and thank you for um those who are
watching um i'm very excited to do this excited to
view a lot of the other presentations that are
being done i think it's a great resource so i'm
going to talk about autism today and autism is a
condition that currently is behaviorally defined
think of making a behavioral diagnosis
of autism when we see that a child
or a young person young adult has um
qualitative differences in social functioning
combined with restricted and repetitive behaviors
and a rigidity of thought that's characteristic
of autism and when we see those things
together and developmental history of those
differences and functioning then you know we make
the call autism however there's vast heterogeneity
in terms of functioning and adaptive behaviors
and severity of symptoms across a wide spectrum of
autistic people and that makes it very difficult
to really um plan for the proper interventions
and the right types of treatments that we want
to select and so you know fundamentally the the
fact that we still rely on um observation and
behavioral diagnosis and developmental history
as opposed to what has happened in other areas of
medicine where we have more biologically informed
diagnoses that would that refer back to the
cause of the causes of a condition so we think
about the cause and we know there are multiple
causes of autism and depending on the biological
mechanisms involved you get this difference in
presentation that we think of as the heterogeneity
on the autism spectrum so this this kind of
lack of biological markers and our inability
to more precisely diagnose autism now plural
thinking about the different causes leads to
a status quo where we have inexact treatments
we tend to apply the same evidence-based
interventions across the spectrum and they work
better or worse for different kids for reasons
that we don't really understand so we have
this broad application of inexact treatments
and that can lead to a lot of wasted time a
lot of failures to optimize progress a lot of
loss of resources for families who are paying
for these interventions and in general you know
most importantly a lack of helping the child
and helping the child's family to optimize
the outcomes for the kids so a lot of the work
that i want to show you today is aimed at trying
to understand the different causes of autism try
and trying to pursue different biological markers
that might help us directly address that
problem of a lack of mechanistically informed
indicators and diagnostic instruments for
autism as well as prognostic indicators of
what would work best for which kids all right so
something that i want to emphasize from the outset
is that while our work is translational
in nature and we're hoping that the
work that we do will have a direct impact on
families it's built upon almost a decade now
of of really basic science that has advanced
our understanding of different components of
the human brain and how those components interact
so you know for in the first editions of the kind
of bible of of neural science principles of neural
science there were chapters devoted to cognition
to language to motor function but little mention
of social functioning which seems kind of funny
now when we think about it because you know
that's such an important component of being
human you know how we interact with other people
how we understand other people's intentions and
how we understand other people's perspectives
but around you know the late 1990s early 2000s
there was really a revolution in neuroscience
cognitive neuroscience using different imaging
techniques to start to understand that there was
a chapter yet to be written on the social brain
and so the concept of the social brain is that we
have dedicated systems for processing the actions
and intentions of other people and that we can
very rapidly and readily use these dedicated
systems they're modules but they're interconnected
with other systems that do other things language
higher order reasoning executive function even
our our action systems from promoter responses
and they're they're central to our understanding
of other people and then informing the rest of
our brain as to what actions or what words
we want to use in order to respond to kind
of a complex to and fro with other individuals
and one of the little bits of the social brain
that will feature prominently today just one
component that plays an important role in
what now is understood as a widely distributed
system is the superior temporal sulcus region
and this is a part of the brain that processes
what we call biological or social motion and
this is a little movie you're seeing now back in
the early 2000s was high-end virtual reality now
it's a little bit of a joke when we talk about
virtual reality compared to what we can do now
but it was a simple experiment where we were
showing in typically developing college students
different types of motion be they you know
people moving or even a robot moving like a
person compared to for example a little caricature
of a grandfather clock or a mixed up um robot that
was upside down and the parts were all mixed up
so that you didn't see it as a person walking
and what this early study showed was that there
were regions of the brain especially along the
temporal lobe just above your your right mostly
in the right hemisphere just above your ear that
respond quite strongly to biological motion and
are dedicated to processing that type of motion
but don't respond to other types of motion
and so that was a early demonstration that
the brain already just in seeing people
moving starts to treat other people in
the environment differently than it does
other moving objects in the environment and
other types of visual information coming in so
it tags it as having special significance and
applies a whole set of computations to it
that aren't aren't used for other stimuli
and what's really striking about this
is that even from the first days of
postnatal life human infants and
actually a lot of other species
treat the the movements of their
species so humans look at human movement
already from birth very differently than they do
other types of movement it's as though they're
pre-programmed by a combination of genetics and
prenatal experience to hone in on that type of
motion and see it as unique and interesting
and learn from it something that allows them
to progress through their social development
so um i'm excited now that there's actually a
chapter on the social brain and the new principles
of neuroscience textbook so we've come a long way
and it's that basic science that really supports
our efforts to look for biological markers
so one of the earliest studies we did of children
with autism we're putting them inside the
mri magnet we were taking pictures of their brain
as they were watching either coherent biological
motion which is this is a good example of that so
they're watching these little point light displays
they're called these have been used in psychology
for many decades to study you know how we process
um motion and then you know more recently once mri
came along and started to be used starting to be
used a lot in cognitive neuroscience of using
these stimuli to study social perceptions see
in this case you have a person being filmed
doing patty cake actually a sort of a child
friendly interaction and then the scrambled
biological or non-social notion now i'm playing
that next to it and that's just the same exact
point lights but now scrambled up in a way that
hopefully no one would recognize as socially
meaningful even though you might recognize it as
equally somewhat equally interesting because
it's moving around in a kind of random way
and so we had these two stimuli and we would show
versions of these different actions and different
scrambled actions to kids with autism while they
were in the magnet and we did this study um you
know on a large number of participants over
time and so at some point we started using the
brain scans that would result from this in
a much more data science oriented way and
we did some machine learning to see if we could
use the patterns of activity that we would see
from kids watching these different types of
movies across several different studies so
typically developing kids and kids with autism
to see if we could go in and start to identify
you know what are the parts of the brain and how
they're interacting that best separate individuals
with autism from typically developing individuals
in a diagnostic sense and so we did this
using some machine learning algorithms where
we first had a discovery set so we had you know
known the computer you know we were telling it
okay you know these are um kids without autism
um and these are kids with autism hopefully
you're able to see my mouse there moving around
um and you know we're saying okay learn
the different features of the data set
these imaging voxels and their activity
over time so in essentially four dimensional
space including time where we could differentiate
the people the kids with them without autism and
the computer algorithm is learning up you
know how to do this and then we used a much
larger replication data set by virtue of doing
this type of scanning over a long period of time
with many kids and we said okay you know now
we're not going to give you any hints about
who has the diagnosis and who doesn't we want the
computer to apply what it learned and see how well
it does in a new data set and the results i think
were really intriguing so let me lead you through
this so so panel a here sorry a panel a is showing
you the parts of the brain that best differentiate
kids with and without autism okay and
these are components that we have come
to be called the fusiform face area fusiform
gyrus lateral fusiform gyrus to be specific
and the part of the brain i already mentioned
this right superior temporal sulcus region
these were the regions that statistically speaking
did the best job at differentiating kids with and
without autism now i want to bring you down to c
here for a moment you notice this says all boys
and this is a receiving operate operator
characteristic curve and these are often
used to display data that we want to use for
making diagnostic decisions in in medicine
and what this is suggesting is that our model did
quite a real quite a good job on area under the
curve here of 0.77 of differentiating boys with
autism from typically developing boys and um you
know if you're if you're either expert on this
type of data or you know you're you're carefully
listening to my words you notice i went from
kids with autism to boys with autism so when
you look up here at panel b you'll notice
that for girls with and without autism
our model did a terrible job at differentiating
girls with autism from typically developing girls
in fact it almost uh well in fact it did do
worse than chance which is um kind of hard to do
either we broke math or the
social brain is actually
more active and more connected in girls with
autism than typically developing girls which
is something we'll return to in a few minutes
and so on the one hand we were very excited that
we had a an example of a potential biological
marker that could distinguish kids with and
without autism but on the other hand we were
disappointed that it seemed to only work
for boys and then at the same time very
intrigued as to why it doesn't work for
girls and this was in the greater context of
findings within genetics that girls with autism
in order to receive the diagnosis of autism needed
to have a stronger or larger genetic hit in order
to get to the same behavioral diagnosis at the
same time in that context was knowledge that
oftentimes girls were going undiagnosed until
later in development oftentimes whereas the
average for diagnosing a boy with autism let's
say might be two to three years of age for a girl
was pushed back at least a couple of
years to four or five and there were
many clinical anecdotes of girls who were
really not getting diagnosed until the early
late pre-teen early teen years where they were
really facing greater social challenges at school
that kind of led to them getting
in some disciplinary trouble
and then upon kind of really being noticed at that
point we're getting the type of diagnostic care
that led to a diagnosis of autism and it wasn't
that they had become autistic later they were
always autistic it's just that our diagnostic
process had had really missed them and they
hadn't been brought to the attention of people
who could do a reliable diagnosis and so they were
the girls with autism in general are a
much greater risk for for suffering from
the effects of getting a later diagnosis and we
can go into that a little bit later as well um
beyond the obvious additional loss of time for
intervention as well as the social isolation
and the social um ostracism that comes along with
being different especially when um you think about
girls and boys as they enter middle school and
kind of make the transition into high school
so we were um on the one hand disappointed
on the other hand intrigued because of these
genetic findings and these findings of girls who
were being diagnosed late both because they were
being missed by standard diagnostic channels and
also suggestions that they were able to camouflage
their autism and so that kind of relates back
to this notion of doing worse than chance here
in panel b in the sense that um you know
our girls that have a diagnosis of autism
and how do they become quite adept at being able
to socially adapt so much so that they're actually
have increased activity somewhat suggesting
increased work of the social brain trying to
fit in and then how does that affect other aspects
of brain development for them because you think
back to a couple slides ago and i was talking
about how the typically developing social brain
very effortlessly processes other
people's intentions and their actions
and helps you fit in socially in
this case it's suggesting that
the girls with autism are accomplishing some of
this but they're they're doing it at a very high
cost in terms of the energy being devoted quite
literally to their social brain and you know what
does that pull away from and how exhausted they
must feel and how does it perhaps relate to a very
common observation among studies of girls with
autism of diagnostic comorbidity down the road
where greater rates of depression
and anxiety and eating disorders
in those girls that we we see some of in
boys with autism but nowhere near the same
type of comorbidity and levels of mental
illness that we see in the girls with autism so
on the one hand a good demonstration of how
we can apply advanced data science techniques
to begin to identify a biomarker but then
suggesting that much more work needs to be done
in order to begin to identify you know what
is different about girls with autism and so
the university of virginia is the the lead site
for a network of locations that are studying
girls of autism they include some really great
universities including university of washington
at seattle university of california los angeles
harvard yale children's national hospital and
george washington university in dc and of course
the university of virginia and we're studying
girls with autism across this network in part
because one of the strongest kind of biological
findings in the field of autism is that autism is
much more prevalent in boys versus girls now this
is true of all almost all neurodevelopmental
disorders in the sense that boys truly are
the weaker sex when it comes to neurodevelopmental
conditions and neurodevelopment in general we're
much more susceptible to just about every
neurodevelopmental condition psychiatric condition
um than girls but it's even more
so in autism to the extent that we
think about those genetics findings that
i mentioned earlier that girl development
both genetically and in terms of brain
development and perhaps social programming
is protective against developing autism so we
needed a network because we needed to recruit
as many girls as possible in statistics
or epidemiology we call that over sampling
and so we're over sampling for girls we're
also studying boys with autism we're still
interested in boys with autism in this network
of course but we wanted to oversample for girls
and so what we're doing is a mixed methods
approach so the university of virginia in addition
to being the administrative lead of the network is
also the home of the data coordinating center and
that's actually led by jack van horn and what jack
is is leading is where we're recruiting and then
taking biological samples so blood and saliva
and we're taking electrophysiological data
and we're taking functional magnetic resonance
imaging data from all of these kids and then
extensive and actually i should say they're
now young adults older adolescents and young
adults this is a longitudinal study what jack's
helping us do is bring together all of that data
so that we can begin to look at the integration
of different levels of analysis of the human
organism from genes to brain to behavior to
social context and understand the bi-directional
interactions within and across those levels of
analysis over time and then that we hope will
lead to greater insights into the development of
on one hand kids with without autism and then sex
differences in those patterns of development and
also sex differences within patterns of typical
development okay so show you one example of where
we're sort of going with this this slide is simply
showing you that across our or now fairly large
data set when we look at processing of social
information what we see is that in boys we again
replicate this finding that their social brain
is different that they have less activity and
less connectivity among social brain regions
in in comparison to typically developing
boys when we look at girls with autism the
those differences are absent and relative to
typically developing girls what they have is much
less activity in regions of the brain involved
in processing higher order integration of that
information so it seems it almost suggests that
they're sort of using their social brain they're
over using their social brain to to process this
type of information without passing it along to
higher order executive prefrontal regions and
more action-oriented regions that would allow
them to use that lower-level social information
to to begin to process that information and use
it in in service of their moment-to-moment
interactions and so that fits very well
with you know how girls with autism often present
which is that they might be very interested in
social interaction that's in contrast to
many boys with autism and they might be
good at certain aspects of it but then can be um
terrible at higher more higher level more subtle
aspects of social interaction so they might
overwhelm a social partner and not know when
to kind of you know sit back and interact
less and sort of give that to and fro and
um in that can become you know alienated and
ridiculed for being socially awkward as opposed to
for boys they might present as kind
of uninterested in social interaction
and a lot of times in terms of kind of standards
of behavior for boys that's much less socially
damaging to one's reputation
than being awkward or bad at it
if you kind of follow my meaning there so
we also began as i mentioned to integrate
you know gene data so genetic data in this case
whole exome sequencing and what we did here was
look at the patterns of brain activity in the
regions that differentiated girls with autism
from typically developing girls during social
inter social perception and we looked at that in
contrast to a transcriptome of the human brain
that was available from studies of of brains
in dip totally separate from the subjects we
looked at from prenatal development to early
infancy via autopsy and then what part what genes
are expressed in which parts of the brain and we
made a map that had the overlap brain regions that
we identified as being different in the girls with
autism versus the genes that were expressed most
expressed in those regions of the brain in early
development and that created a essentially a
criteria gene set that was limited by location
from our fmri data and then we looked within
that and lo and behold what we found was that
girls with autism were much more likely to have
genetic hits when we looked at their actual whole
exome sequencing data in terms of copy number
variations single nucleotide variations so these
subtle genetic changes that were were meaningful
in terms of affecting a synthesis of a protein
what our data showed was that we could use the
imaging data to put a spotlight on which genes
that we should be looking at and then when we turn
that spotlight on we saw this very big difference
between the number of genetic hits among
girls with autism compared to boys with autism
and ultimately what this suggested was that
sorry about that what this suggested is that
both at the level of brain function and the
genetics involved in autism in genetic i should
say genetic involvement genetics involved
in autism the genes that drive girl autism
might be very different than the genes that drive
boy autism and the way we got to that discovery
was using the imaging data to focus in on which
genes we should be paying careful attention to
and we're excited to see that both within our
data set and then when we went to a totally
different data set in this case the simon simplex
collection we were able to replicate that finding
in the simon simplex collection so we had not
only in our ace network data evidence of this a
discovery of this but then we had a replication
of it in a totally new data set which of course
is a critically important step for for anything
in science but in particular when we're thinking
about the number of leads within autism that we've
seen in our lab and all other you know other labs
as well that then don't pan out in a new data
set it was particularly um heartwarming that we
you know could see this in a new data set
so excited about that now i focused on um
social behavior social perception but that's not
the only story within the field of autism in terms
of trying to understand what's going on what's
different in the brains of people with autism
it's really just the lens through which
my group has looked most carefully
another approach to this is is an entirely
data-driven approach where we don't really apply
any preconceived theory but we say okay let's
let's let the brains tell us what's going what's
going on what's different one way to do that is
through resting state data and so resting state
is exactly what it sounds like you put the person
into the mri machine you you help them relax you
know and you tell them either close your eyes and
just kind of zone out or keep your eyes open and
look at a little crosshair on the screen so we're
sort of controlling um you know what they're doing
and just letting their brains kind of wander
and we measure activity over time and the
correlation between different regions of
the brain and we did that in this case
and then we said okay what are the underlying
latent network organizations that best identify
girls with autism from typically developing girls
and boys with autism from typically developing
boys and that gave us essentially two maps of
the brain and differences in the brain and then
that these were statistical maps in these three
dimensions that said okay this part of the brain
this set of coordinates is showing a nice
difference between boys with and without autism
over here this is a part of the brain
that shows the difference of girls with
autism we could take that
data that spatial organization
and look in a resource that's online it's called
neuroscience which is a it's a really cool
website in a sense that you can type in you
know three-dimensional coordinates of the
brain and it will tell you um it will query all
of the available imaging studies that have been
mined and for this database and tell you you know
what constructs in psychology have been talked
about you know so if you put in a coordinate that
corresponds to broca's area for example um in the
inferior frontal gyrus it'll come back with a
whole list of studies that have talked about
that part of the brain in terms of producing
speech and perhaps mirror neurons as well and it
will rank order the constructs based on how many
studies and what level of statistical significance
was found within those studies for that
region corresponding to that construct
and for us this was exciting because we could
submit our maps and get essentially a diagram
of what constructs map onto the different latent
networks that we had identified that best defined
autism in girls versus autism with boys and then
we turned that into you know what's commonly
called a wordle or word olds these days and what
you're seeing on screen now the top outlined there
in pink is the wordle for the girls their network
to construct mapping and the size of the font
the you know the size of the words corresponds
to the statistical significance of the finding
and then you can see the same thing for boys below
it outlined in blue there and for boys that this
comes as no surprise to anyone who thinks a
lot about autism studies autism you know that
certainly at the core of the behavioral definition
of autism is differences in social perception
in language comprehension and person perception
and then of course those were the most significant
constructs that that popped out of this analysis
but the data from girls actually really stunned us
in the sense that we had to go pretty far down the
list before we found anything that corresponded to
a similarity with boys um language comprehension
being really the only one and the the
strongest relations in terms of constructs
were anxiety and emotional regulation
and these aren't core characteristics of autism
this isn't you know you don't need to have anxiety
and emotional regulation difficulties for example
in order to receive the diagnosis of autism
but for girls oftentimes it's problems with
anxiety and difficulties in emotional regulation
that get them to be seen by the proper clinicians
who are able to make an autism diagnosis
and as far as parents are concerned across
boys and girls anxiety and emotional regulation
differences are often the and difficulties
are often the things most cited as being
most problematic this is commonly referred to as
autistic meltdowns that are happening well beyond
the developmental stage where meltdowns are
appropriate and and they cause a lot of trouble
for the individual and the family in general
especially as the individual gets older might
be physically stronger and more imposing these
are the kinds of things that get young people
in trouble and so this is um was quite striking to
us and really gave us pause in the sense that what
the data was telling us what the brain activity
was really telling us is that the underlying
circuits that are different in girls with
autism are different from the differences in
boys with autism and that you know kind of at a
first pass even though it's by no means perfect
um we could begin to think about autism being
reflected in the brain very differently for
boys and girls and that should have obvious
implications for how we approach intervention
and treatment and you know this broader concept
of precision medicine precision intervention so
next thing i want to show you um is is an
application of that concept of precision medicine
having talked a lot about differences between boys
and girls i want to put that away for a minute
and turn back to a broader focus of autism in
general and i want to show you an example of where
we've taken a well-known evidence-based behavioral
intervention it's called pivotal response
treatment the details of the intervention are so
important just knowing that we weren't interested
in determining whether or not pivotal response
training is a is an effective intervention we
already knew it was based on the literature but we
wanted to know could we use imaging to understand
how it works you know what what does it
change in terms of the developing brain and
can we begin to predict for whom it will work okay
and what i should tell you about pivotal response
training like almost every behavioral intervention
for autism it's a very time consuming and often
extremely expensive especially if insurance
isn't paying for it um intervention that
requires quite a bit of commitment and time from
the family you know typically speaking in our case
we gave children 16 weeks of um of pivotal
response training prt for short and about 25
thirty hours a week so very intensive some
of that was done in our laboratory at the
um at the el child study center and some of it
was done in the home and so this required a parent
to bring that it would usually mom to the young
child study center or make their home open to us
meaning that the parent and the child were there
and you start thinking about this something that
could be very expensive you know if you think
about a 16 week course of prt it would be
costing a family if they were paying without
insurance about 30 000 for the intervention
with insurance it would be less but still
a substantial financial commitment we were
giving it for free because it was for research
but if you think about that that's really
that's quite a burden and it requires one parent
to be available you know 20 30 hours a week which
means that parent really can't hold a full-time
job and of course for many families there is
only one parent so you think about all of that
the stakes of being able to predict which kids
will benefit from a given intervention become very
high you know it's not just an academic exercise
if truly we can do a good job at predicting then
we can do something very very meaningful for
families so this is a complex slide i'm going to
unpack it the first thing i want you to look at is
the different lines on this graph showing
pre and post and the measurement here is this
the level of social symptoms measured by the
social responsiveness scale for each individual
child who is in this study each child is is
a black line here and this is coming into the
study their level of symptoms and this is after
16 weeks of intervention their level of symptoms
and what this is showing is a degree a high degree
of heterogeneity in how well the kids respond to
pivotal response training so you see that
some of them changed very very little
going up higher is is worse it's more symptoms so
if they're responding to the treatment well you
see they start here and they go down in terms of
level of symptoms so some kids responded very well
some really didn't respond at all and a few got a
little bit worse which is common in all clinical
trials and then the red line is the mean and
when we say evidence-based intervention usually
what we mean is that on average kids get better
have fewer symptoms are doing better our primary
outcome measure and that of course was true here
but think about all this heterogeneity for some
kids this was a waste of time and um and for their
parents as well and maybe even an intrusion and so
thinking about this slide now we look at the using
these machine learning techniques to identify
the parts of the brain that best respond and
best predict whether or not an individual will
do well so best divi the parts of the brain that
really best help us understand the cytogeneity
these are four clusters of activity that help
do that and so cluster one is in the posterior
superior temple sulcus and that's a region
mentioned several times it's involved in really
indicating and processing other people's actions
and intentions this is a region of the brain in
the parietal cortex that's involved in
distributing and maintaining attention
a region of the insula and
ventral medial prefrontal cortex
ventrilateral prefall cortex it's involved
cluster three um widely known to be involved
in emotion regulation and being able to
regulate your behavior to to engage in
an ongoing activity and this last cluster
here the ventral striatum and the amygdala
very sensitive to reward including social rewards
so finding an social interaction rewarding
and what this is saying is that to the extent
that these brain regions are active and connected
in terms of their activity the child will
do better that's what this graph is showing
in pivotal response training now a lot
of times when i talk about this data um
if there are clinicians in the audience they'll
kind of say yeah so you just told me that if
a child can notice social information and pay
attention to it and if they can regulate their
behavior and interact with me and if they find it
rewarding they'll do well in the the intervention
that you're talking about and that seems kind
of obvious it's like yes but i'm doing two
things that that that are deeper than that simple
observation one is these are quantitative measures
that vary by child of levels of those
constructs that we just mentioned in passing
that really don't have a reliable and sensitive
measure out there in nature that can be used by a
clinician to make a decision and in fact when we
looked at all of our behavioral data and all of
our clinician ratings we found that that data in
contrast to the brain data just did a terrible job
of predicting which kids would benefit from the
treatment and one of the simplest things we did
was ask expert clinicians do you think this child
is a good candidate for this treatment can you
estimate how well they'll respond and there's so
there's funny things that happen within cognitive
cognitive psychology talks about these extensively
that when you're an expert in something
it becomes it can become very challenging for
certain reasons because of cognitive biases
to make a judgment about a particular
case and and so actually our imaging
approach was doing a much better job than even
some of the very best clinicians in the country
when they reviewed the files and saw videos
of these kids and sometimes met them in person
of being able to predict so we were doing a
very good job of predicting and that's fine
but we were also showing quite literally
parts of the brain that if they were
active and connected during the intervention
if we ramped them up prior to the intervention
the hypothesis that we're putting forward
is that that would actually allow us
to be able to turn a kid who wouldn't have been
a good responder into a good responder and that
for us was very very exciting so last thing that
um next the last thing that i want to show you
is another study separate study that we did
where we used oxytocin which is a molecule that
affects social behavior and it's known to affect
the social brain we gave it to kids with autism
and what we're able to show this is a double-blind
placebo-controlled study we're able to show that
there was a high degree of overlap between the
areas of the brain that a single dose of oxytocin
would activate and make more interconnected
relative to placebo there was a high degree
of overlap between those parts of the brain
and the parts of the brain that predict
good outcomes and good response to pivotal
response training and so you can sort of see
where we're going with this is that perhaps we've
got an approach where imaging can allow us to use
a pharmacological agent a very targeted
way for kids who don't have the activity
that they need to take part in pivotal response
training successfully to give it to them to
boost their response to the pivotal response
training for example and we think this can
apply to any evidence-based intervention
but right now we're actually studying this
with funding from the simons foundation to see
if we can indeed take those kids who don't have
the activity initially and help boost it nice to
mention that you know we've been talking about
kids broadly and what i'm really talking
about is is four five six year olds and above
but of course autism is a condition that
we can see evidence of very very early in
development so ultimately we want
to push back our ability to study
the precursors and the biological markers of
autism to the earliest points possible and so
we're using a lot of measures in addition to fmri
um where we're able to scan babies but we're not
able to routinely scan babies it's not trivial we
can't sedate them and so we're waiting for them to
fall asleep and and then get images of their brain
in order to allow us to do some of this precision
medicine approaches we have other techniques
including optical imaging and electrophysiology
that allow us to go in and study some of
the same concepts with a child who's active
and attending much much younger than we're used
to studying so the last thing i want to show you
this is actually being led up by megan puglia who
is a an expert in working with very young infants
and she's working with the
neonatal intensive care unit
team here at uva and where what we're hoping to
do is really begin to take some of the techniques
that we have in some of the eeg signatures
that she has electrophysiology and apply it
to even very very young infants and there we're
not necessarily predicting what interventions
would work but rather can we predict a diagnosis
of autism much sooner earlier in development so
that we can begin to to develop interventions for
even very young infants so that we can start to
affect the developmental trajectory and prevent
it from going towards an autistic trajectory
even before the onset of obvious symptoms
and so leave you there hopefully it generates
some questions and just one last slide to
thank the funders of this research and of
course the families who have made this possible
by allowing us to to study their kids and to
meet their kids and take these brain
images i'll stop there for questions
thank you so much kevin that was uh fantastic
autism is such a challenging disorder and
i mean one of the things which was clearly
evident is that what we've been doing up with
just you know a clinical assessment up until
fairly recently has really been inadequate to
tell the difference between boys with autism
and girls with autism in particular and you
mentioned something about the genes for girls
possibly being different than the genes for boys
with autism what do we know about the genetics
of asd in the context of it's it's clearly not
one gene maybe it's multiple genes may if they're
sex linked at all perhaps that's explanatory what
do we know about that and maybe you can explain
some of that sure so as you mentioned there's no
one gene that's been discovered that you know
causes autism every time when it when it's
different or present or absent
bigger or smaller but there are
a number of genes that increase the risk for
developing autism and every time i say the number
it's tomorrow it'll grow but i think the numbers
around about 100 right now of high confidence
autism candidate genes that separately or
in combination greatly increase the risk
for developing autism and in addition so those are
kind of high penetrant genes and then in addition
there are many many genes that contribute to
risk in sort of the background of common genetic
variation um that taken in isolation really don't
increase the risk of autism but when you start
putting certain common genetic variation together
in certain patterns and then possibly combine it
with rare genetic variation that is much more
likely to directly cause autism you get this
this tapestry of many genes it could
be hundreds or thousands that then
give you you know a much increased risk for
autism and even then it's not deterministic
so you could have a lot of autism risk genes
and still not develop autism you could have one
autism risk gene and develop autism and so it's
it's non-deterministic and very very complex
and then overlay on that the fact that
some of those genes are sex-linked
and then that some of those genes play different
roles in brain development depending upon
whether they're in a boy brain or a girl brain
and the different genetic background of boys and
girls so not necessarily sex linked per se but
in the milieu of what genes do depending
on whether they're in the presence of
female or male brain development and the
hormonal milieu going on that you get an
even more complicated picture so for example
at first blush from our data the genes that
seem to be hits and candidate genes for
boys with autism and autism in general
are related to synaptic development to pruning
of synapses to glial development as well
whereas in girls with autism a lot of what
we're seeing in terms of the gene modules gene
expression modules that we're finding seem to
be more involved with inflammatory response and
and control and regulation of that inflammatory
response that's super interesting so as we kind of
reaching the top of the hour here i'm curious of
your your thoughts on are there any data resources
that are available for people who would want
to say take a look at some of these different
data types that you mentioned and finally just
what's the role of data science in helping to
make progress understanding autism disorder
spectrum disorders yeah yeah sure so you know
one data resource of course is our network and
you know since we're the data coordinating center
and jack you're the lead of that
being able to collaborate on that data
get access to the de-identified data and
utilize it for different projects is fairly
straightforward in addition there's more broadly
what's called the um well i call it indar jack
remind me of what it's now called what's the
the nimh data archive thank you thank you
used to be called the national database for
autism research and it was autism focused
now it's broader so they changed the name but it
still contains the autism data from i don't know
many many studies funded by nih that have
contributed to this and were required to
contribute to this archive as condition of the
grant funding and so you can find incredible you
know wealth of data in that archive that can be
used and integrated different data types linked by
an individual unique identifier that's that's
still private but will allow you to know
which individual the data came from and then
there also are european similar data sets that
are available eu aims is one i can't speak to
how open it is as a resource but it's it's there
so those are three at least and uh you
know data sets that are that are readily
mineable and in terms of the role of data
science you know it it's absolutely essential
any of the methods that i sort of
flashed on the screen you know eeg
fmri behavioral data that we collect
clinical data genetics each of those can
tell you some cool things in isolation and
of course data science techniques are used
i highlighted machine learning several
times there but really it's the cross data
formats interactions that data science is so
good at generating and handling the giant data
sets and bringing together the different types
to inform much more advanced biological questions
um that where data science shines and is
essential to this endeavor you know so
otherwise it would just be silos of researchers
working using their method and publishing the
next paper that's kind of logical extension
and that's important and fine but it's the
bridging across all of those different silos and
bringing together the data to to address advanced
questions that is driving the field forward
um and going after the most important concepts
well thank you so much kevin for sharing
with us your research and your vision for
the study of autism spectrum disorder it is
clearly a complex neuroscience challenge data
science is clearly required to sift through and
integrate these multiple different data types
and i i hope that some of our uh participants
in our foundation or our sorry a biomedical
data science innovation lab activities will look
to this as a potential uh project idea um anyway
thank you very much kevin very much appreciate
it thank you everybody who tuned in and uh we'll
look forward to seeing you next week thanks
so much enjoy your weekend okay thank you